[Music]
on today's show we discuss how to talk
to a little kid about divorce
when they miss their dad
we talk about
how do you connect with your partner's
ex-husband when you're raising a step
kid we talk to a wife whose husband just
plays on youtube and won't get a job
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john maloney's show
so glad you're here
mental health relationships parenting
i don't know whatever weird religions
you whatever we talk about all of it i'm
so glad you're with us thanks for being
here if you want to be on this show go
to johndaloni.com
ask ask we have we talked to real people
about real stuff going on in your life
johndeloney.com
ask fill out the form
and it will go to kelly and she will
she's one who puts together these shows
she's the greatest call screen on planet
earth and she'll reach out to you and
get you on the show or if you want to
call and leave a message it's
1-844-693-3291
it's one eight four four six nine three
thirty two
ninety one james kelly huge news huge
news
did we hit number one on anything
no not even close
um
did uh
are we suddenly getting huge pay raises
no all this is
nothing is going to compare what i'm
about to tell you
somebody on the internet named will
rankin
r-a-n-k-i-n
sent me a uh
internet's message an instagram uh they
called him uh
did he slide into my dms is that bad is
that what he did
i
honestly don't know
yes he did just
yeah i shouldn't say that
depends on what he said oh i see what
you i see what you did there
he sent me a photo
and i realized
people are driving and they're thinking
should i turn this down i got kids in
the car number one your kid should not
watch the [ __ ] listen to the show but
he sent me a photo of a prius on the
side of the road that was completely
camo'ed out
it was an all camo prius
with some folks looking for bears or
something i don't know if they're
hunters or whatever
shout out
to i was talking to trash there's no
such thing as a camera camoed prius
i was wrong it's actually kind of
brilliant because they're so quiet they
really could sneak up on oh it's the
greatest hunting vehicle ever
i don't know what kind of animals you're
going to sneak up on to with your giant
f350 going
i don't make you feel good and then you
can get your guns out and go
but dude you get your stealth
christensen rifle put in the back of a
prius
i'm just trying to picture like whatever
you kill strapped to the hood or the top
of a prius
did i not talk about that on the show
i'll tell you off air i know people will
have their feelings about hunting but my
first experience deer hunting
me and my son were in a prius and
just tell it just tell me
i just didn't expect that we would
harvest anything
and
we did it was like the buck of a
lifetime i'll never in my life
experience this again and all we had was
a prius and you should have seen the
man's face when we took him to the place
where they
processed the deer
and he said pull around back so i pulled
around back and here's me and my son
sitting there all camo'ed up in a bright
white prius my wife's car
and an 11-point buck in the back and it
made for one of the more awkward
exchanges of my life and awesome i have
a great photo that just has
like a rifle in the deer my son's asleep
on it and my boots and then right above
the deer is it says prius inside
just one of those prized possessions
we're definitely adding that in post
the photo
it's pretty awesome and i realized
some of you were just like i'm
cancelling him he's a hunt dude let's do
whatever we'll have that show later on
but hey there is a camo prius out in the
wild whoever's it is congratulations to
you i tip my hat to you and will rankin
thanks for sliding into my dms and
sending me
that photo is that how you say that
i think they're they're i think there's
a connotation to sliding in the dms so
he just sent you a dm he sent me a photo
yeah they're on the internets of a car
does that mean like someone wants to
like hook up
oh yeah when you say that with he sent
me a photo that connotation is not not
great yeah
okay
i'm hey you know what
for those under the age of 72 back there
i'm proud of you james kelly you really
let the team down you could have hooked
me up
you all are all nodding yeah that's
exactly how you say that dude just say
somebody slit in your dms and send a
photo just say that thanks guys all
right let's go to stacy in orlando
florida stacy what's going on
hi dr john um so i am at the tail end of
a divorce um i
have been yeah
i have been married for 13 years
um
my well i guess soon-to-be ex-husband
has struggled on and off with a an
addiction
to what started with it started with um
pain
pills
um and then it progressed to her heroin
now yeah yeah and um he was he was clean
for like many years uh he had like a
good
uh long stretch for like about five
years and enough to make you believe
yes exactly reattach way at the
[Music]
his brother passed and that led him to
spiral
out of control and
he just has not been able to get a
handle on it and so
you have little ones uh
yes i have a four-year-old son oh geez
um and so we've been separated a year
now um
going through the divorce process
um in the divorce documents it states
that he's not allowed to have a
relationship with our son unless he is
clean because they didn't want the
inconsistency in his life no don't
apologize for that at all that's the
right move okay uh and he has to thank
you and he has to provide clean drug
tests every month in order to do that
and
so right now i have sole custody of
course of my son and um
he because of that
he has not we haven't seen him or my son
hasn't seen or heard from him since
christmas
um he's put in a really dark place right
now like he's really it's really bad um
and so my son is four so he's still
really young but
um he still has memories of his dad and
he brings him up you know um
you know
remembering like he took him fishing and
that kind of stuff and he'll bring up
memories but my question i have two
two-part questions so one is
um
when my son does ask where's my dad um
when he sees like other kids and their
dad still sometimes asks me i never know
what the right thing to say is
um like how do i i know he's four and
he's still young but i i want to handle
it the right way
daddy's sick
daddy's sick he doesn't understand
addiction he doesn't understand any of
those things all he understands is i
miss my dad
yeah exactly and so um
you can never ever ever ever talk bad
about his dad
no i never would he's he's actually he's
a great guy he's a great man he was a
great father great husband i have no
bad things to say about him um he's just
battling some demons
there you go and so okay
now daddy's sick and um
i miss him a lot and i know you miss him
too stinks huh
and if you're in a position not to um
not to try to fill every role that's
that's the hard part about being a
single mom so if it's do you miss
fishing yeah
you figure out how to go fishing go get
yourself two cheap zebcos at academy or
walmart or something and take him
somewhere you may not catch anything but
it may be hilarious you may be an
incredible fisherman who knows
but there's some of those things that
you may have to learn how to throw a
ball or kick something or you all those
things you know that that's the world
you found yourself in um but daddy's
sick is the best way to tell a
four-year-old that over time
sooner rather than later right so you
think you've got until sixth or seventh
grade you don't you've got short time
here
um
your son will put pieces together he'll
hear stories he'll talk to grandma he'll
do something and he'll start to put it
together
and as honest as you can be
age-appropriate wise
right
so um it may go from daddy's sick to
daddy was taking some medicine to make
him feel better and then the medicine
ended up making him sick too
and um
and so we miss daddy right and then that
may slowly go towards um
that he was doing some adult things
putting some things in his body that
made him really really sick why did
daddy do that well he was really sad and
sick too
isn't it isn't it hurt more sad isn't it
hurt you know what i mean
and a lot a lot a lot of physical
contact with your son when you're having
these conversations
okay okay
for a child physical contact helps calm
the fight-or-flight response
that the loneliness and the missing and
the well i get sad so am i gonna put
things in my right so little kids just
start connecting dots way sooner than we
think but it starts right now with
daddy's just so sick and he can't see us
right now we miss him don't we
acknowledge it and don't ever brush away
his feelings in his sadness
okay i'm so sorry
thank you what was the second part
the second part was
if if he doesn't ever get it together
because obviously there's like a high
chance that that's very possible with a
heroin addiction um
what is the age appropriate time to have
like that conversation like the real
conversation because i want to warn him
um because
i i know and i don't to you know hide
that from him because it does run in his
family you know his dad had it his
grandfather had it his great-grandfather
his sister is currently struggling with
an eating disorder so i know that he's
like predisposed to
an addictive
personality or behavior so i want to
warn him but obviously like make it
age-appropriate so how would i handle
that the warning
so what you're trying to do is solve a
connection issue cognitively
okay and that's not what we're gonna do
here
okay there will come a season when he's
gonna have to make hard choices
but he's four right now
and so what we're gonna do in his life
is we're going to stop the tide
now what we've learned um some pretty
remarkable research i want you to get
the book it's called in the realm of
hungry ghosts by gabor mate
g-a-b-o-r-m-a-t-e and we'll link to it
in the show notes
it's the single greatest book on
addiction i've ever read
but what we're finding is addiction a
lot of these things start with maternal
stress they start in the womb
and when you grow up loving somebody
who's an addict and you grow up loving
somebody who
is an incredible guy a good person who
lives in chaos
and who makes has made terrible choices
um you have been living on the other end
of this thing right so you've been
experiencing trauma too
and then you go through five years of
peace time
and you allow yourself over five years
to connect deeply and to believe yet
again and then it goes off the rails oh
and you're pregnant by the way right so
all the stuff your son's grown up in a
world of chaos
okay
and what your job is is to not try to
warn him cognitively
your job is to make his home
as stable and as loving and as connected
as humanly possible
okay okay
and that means you
you are gonna have to do your work
you're gonna have to heal from this
you're gonna have to show him what
healing looks like you're gonna have to
let him see you be sad and let him see
you get up when you're sad and go make
dinner or go take him on a walk or he's
gonna have to see you exercise he's
gonna have to see you have friends
he's gonna have to see you do budgets
every month and so he's gonna sit down
with you right so he's gonna watch you
and he's gonna be able to put the dots
together there and then his amygdala his
fighter flight is not going to run 24 7
365.
and then when it comes time to make hard
choices and hard decisions
then his
his frontal lobe isn't going to go
offline which it does when he during
chaos
and he's going to be able to make some
of those choices
i also want you to pick up a book called
um it
in the realm of hungry ghosts can be a
little bit dense so feel free to read
over to the most part if you're not a
nerd like i am
but the sentiment is really really good
it's a book about addicts and it's a
book about a doctor who went and worked
with addicts
um the second one is called the deepest
well by dr nadine burke harris
and it's a book on the discovery of aces
adult i mean um adverse childhood
experiences
and i want you to read that book in fact
read that book first
and you will probably be able to look at
your son's life and already start taking
some of these off okay some of these
adverse childhood experiences and it
gives a play-by-play a step by step on
how to help heal children
from these experiences so that they
don't end up adults with these other
challenges
okay okay
i want you to hear me very closely
your son won the lottery with you as his
mommy
okay
thank you
he's lucky lucky to have you
but his journey to wellness his journey
to stopping the cycle his journey to
changing his family tree
doesn't start with more info and threats
it starts with a mom who puts in the
work to get healthy
okay and i put a lot on you just now and
i know that
but you deserve to be
peaceful too
and yep right
yes so you reach out to somebody today
okay oh okay i will you've got a lot of
trauma to heal from too is that right
yes
you've got a childhood to heal from too
right
yes yeah
starts today okay and i want you to keep
me and this squad here uh up to date
give us a email every 30 days or so
every month or so just put on your
calendar right
and we'll walk with you through this
process i'd love to just have you call
and check in with us every couple of
months and we'll have you back on the
show to see how things are going and as
challenges arise as they come up
but you're going to start loving stacy
today
you start loving stacy today
and it starts with you getting well
okay so grateful for you and your little
boy's lucky to have you all right let's
go to noah in san francisco what's up
noah how we doing
hey don dr john doing good how are you
doing good brother what's going on dude
yeah so i'm calling you today because i
would like to get your advice on a
situation that we're dealing with cool
bring it on uh so
my beautiful stepdaughter has turned
five
and she's gotten to the age where she
has realized that me and her biological
dad have never met okay
and being a curious five-year-old she
asked him about it and he told her that
we have never met and that
he won't ever meet me
and did he tell her why or just that he
wouldn't
just that okay
and now she's asking us about it and
we're not really sure how much
information she can handle what should
we tell her
you tell the truth don't ever ever ever
ever lie to your kids
so do you want to see this guy
for her sake i do you know when she gets
older and starts having you know school
events sporting events i would love for
all of us to be able to sit together and
enjoy these things you know for her sake
have you ever reached out to this dude
we've well
through my wife we've tried i've never
personally tried i don't have his phone
number but
we've tried and he just refuses to
so i want you to reach out to him
somebody's got to go first
okay
i want you to be the dad in this
situation i want you to be the the man
in this situation i don't want to gender
it but i want you to be the adult in
this situation
i want you to reach out to him because
y'all are sharing parenting of a
five-year-old little girl
and that's bigger than you being scared
of him him being a acting like a
what a bratty little kid
pisses me off quite honestly like it
makes me mad because there's a little
girl that's suffering at this deal and
i'm not mad at you dude but um i want
you to to
lean in hard on this deal and say hey we
need to go have coffee because we're
co-raising a daughter together
and we need i want to go have coffee
with you man i want to go grab a drink
and i know it's going to be awkward i
know it's going to be hard i know it's
going to be whatever but for the sake of
this little girl i'd love to meet with
you and i'd love to map out a plan so
that you and i are on the same page
and i want you to reach out and do that
and if your wife says no you can't talk
to him that's a problem okay because
y'all are all in this together and when
you married her
you didn't marry him but he's in your
life that's what you signed up for
and whenever they got divorced then he
signed up for there being other people
and at some point he's going to get
remarried and whoever he gets remarried
to is going to be a part of this picture
too so adults have to be adults and
y'all got to get in this thing together
if he won't if he says you know
screw you dude i'm not meeting with you
you know whatever whatever whatever
um
then when your daughter says well why
won't you ever why can't you and daddy
whatever um say we are working on it and
sometimes adults
have hard feelings too but we're working
on it and let that be that
and i want you to circle back every six
months hey brother just checking in man
any chance we could get together talk
about um talk about
whatever your daughter's name is
okay and here's what here's what's gonna
happen in 10 years when she's 16 or 17
one of two things will happen you and
that dude will have made peace with the
world you'll have decided to put her
ahead of y'all's ego
your wife will be in it too and the fact
that she made a child with another dude
she's not just make peace with that
guy's gonna be part of her life forever
um yeah well either a all three of you
be sitting by each other at a band
concert or in the same room or whatever
or at a track meet or whatever is going
on
or you're going to be able to sit down
with your 15 year old daughter and say
hey i'm just going to show you this
here is a track record of the last 10
years
of me reaching out
okay i want you to know that i love you
your mom loves you
your dad loves you
your other dad loves you
um
we've just struggled making
relationships with each other has no
reflection on you whatsoever it's not
about you it's about adults not being
able to get our crap together and i'm
sorry
okay but that's not for years
is that cool yeah
i like the idea of you know setting a
track record something to show her you
know because that's what i'm worried
about you know when she gets later in
life i don't want her to have any type
of feeling or resentment you know
towards that situation
it's going to be less that it's going to
be more
you've got adults speaking into a 15 16
17 year old
almost adult
telling her life things and here's what
she should be doing and here's what a
wisdom and adulthood looks like
and she's gonna have cognitive
dissonance because she's gonna be
witnessing the adults in her life acting
like little babies
does that make sense
and so you're gonna be able to provide
her with a picture of hey i've tried to
control what i could control
and i couldn't bring us all together i
tried your mom's gonna do the same thing
i tried but all three of us love you
crazy
and so all three of us were at the
theater performance we just sat in
different places
and
the the my hope is you keep chipping
away at this dude and he's gonna say
you're right
did their marriage end badly did she
cheat on him or something like what's
his deal
um it ended with some physical violence
very poorly but their relationship has
gotten a lot better over the last four
years which is unfortunately ours has
yet to start so this dude just sucks
yeah pretty much okay so he may be
like if if if he's
if he's an abusive
egomaniac idiot loser he may not be able
to have the courage or
the um maturity
to put his daughter's needs first if
he's the kind of guy that will go hit a
woman he may just be such a spineless
coward
that um he can't put his ego aside
maybe he lost everything including his
daughter including his wife and he
changed
and maybe he's tried to maybe he's
growing up right that's what i'm hoping
for
and you
putting an olive branch out there um
might be an a measure of grace to a guy
who's trying to change his life because
he blew it he lost everything right
and um that may be really incredible
but that that starts with you okay i
wouldn't put that on your wife she's
been abused by this dude she's been
burned by this dude this is the dad of a
stepdaughter okay
are you scared to do that
no not at all you know i i would like to
have a relationship with him you know
because he's the
father of my stepchild you know i love
her so much and i you know like i said
in the future i want to be able to have
something stable for her you know when
she gets older that's right so um do it
because it's right and it's gonna be so
hard um the excuse well i don't have his
number man that's not an excuse that
that should end in about eight seconds
um send him an email that he can write
it to i send him an email and um you all
get onto this right away and at least
make him send him an email and then a
text hey brother i sent you an email
this is so and so this is noah i sent
you an email um
read it and give me a shout
and if he writes you back i'll block you
whatever then you'll deal with that then
but i don't i don't know i'm so
optimistic that people could
just need some connection but i know
that's not always accurate right but um
do the right thing man do the right
thing on behalf of her on behalf of your
marriage for everybody okay do it on
behalf of this guy even though if he
doesn't deserve it reach out for him
all right we'll be right back on the
doctor john eloy's show
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important your
mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy for you video
chat phone or even text chat counseling
with licensed therapists that are going
to help you become a better version of
yourself help you get on the road to
being well go to betterhelp.com10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy and
you're worth it betterhelp.com
deloney take care of yourself start
today
hey what's up we are back let's go to
amy in portland oregon hey amy what's
going on
hi thanks for taking my call of course
thank you for calling the show would be
really lame it's caller show would be
really lame if people like you didn't
call in so what's up how can we help
well i'm calling because um i've been
married for
over 15 years to a really wonderful man
he's kind
supportive can i stop can i just stop
you for some reason
it doesn't work the opposite it doesn't
it doesn't work when husbands call about
their wives
when a wife calls about her husband and
preps it with like 10 different positive
adjectives i know something's coming
so i've been married 15 years he's
wonderful and great and what
and what
just dropped the other shoe
yeah he i've been i am enabling him to
continue to work part-time
to be generally lazy
um to not take care of me and his family
um and to spend time on youtube and
listening to podcasts and and getting
into so into politics and things that
matter just that um i just can't do that
anymore and i'm just wondering how did
we move forward because i'm ready to
do big drastic things that make him
understand this isn't working anymore
i don't
i don't feel like we have ground for
divorce or anything like that but i mean
sometimes i think like do we
separate our money now or do i move out
so we can see that he is dependent on my
money to
keep doing these things and he needs to
work and so i'm just i'm not really sure
how to go forward with this
whoa
there's so much here number one
you started the call with i'm enabling
him
and so
i want to
what's the right thing
i love that you are looking for the
things that you can control
i don't know that you're enabling him
because you're not his mom
and i know that over the last 15 years
he has been way more like a child to you
than your partner and your lover and
your
um
best friend right you've been his mom
for a while is that fair yeah
yeah so in that sense i guess you've
enabled him but he's a grown man
right and so you have
yeah he's a grown man via age so maybe
instead of enabling him you have duct
taped and
nailed and and screwed this family
together you've held it
down
while you've got a um
loser of a husband in the next room
playing video games or like learning the
nest conspiracy theory
right
i don't know if that's enabling as much
as you filled in all the gaps because
you're trying to keep your family
together do you have little kids
we do we have uh two
daughters six and eight who are even
aware of this i mean they ask me like
how can i move you know how come we
don't do that taco and i'm just like
because i'm the only one working
full-time and and they're like what does
that mean and exactly they're getting an
extraordinary picture of what
a uh
what a partner looks like in marriage
right
what a great image for them to carry
around when they start dating oh this is
what um
geez you're going to get me yeah you're
going to get me all fired up yeah yeah
oh man okay so
you've talked to him about this before
what's he say
why won't he get a job why would he work
only turn the stupid computer off
um he he always says i understand i i
know that you're frustrated
and
he he has
typically had one or two part-time jobs
um and sometimes they equal about you
know a full-time amount of work but just
with colin and other things like lack of
ambition and initiative to keep his
non-profit going um it's kind of fizzled
out god what non-profit is it
is this some church-related thing
yeah it's a christian ministry and
that's what's hard because it's not no
so sick
of people using
non-profit christian ministries
to do nothing
to just sit there be like well i'm just
waiting for it's it's it's
an insult to
it's an insult to christian faith it's
an insult to people who are out working
14 hours a day to help feed their
families and help feed their communities
and their neighbors it's an
embarrassment
it's shameful
okay and and
yet in theory these things are great
right in theory they're gonna help but
his is not helping anybody
is it
not currently no it's not it's not it's
not helping any
good pisses me off those things drive me
crazy no i just want to i just want to
start go get a job
go get a job and then take money and
give it to home do that right
um i just so god's called me to quit
everything and just um for my wife to
work full time while i sit here and surf
the internet and
oh my
my gosh it makes me rage out
so when you say you're about to do
drastic things what are you gonna do
well um about six months ago i told them
that i was going to leave if we didn't
get a part-time job were you being
serious or were you threatening
no i was serious i had told him i had
shown him the places i was looking into
moving into why haven't you left yeah
i had figured out a budget i don't think
you're actually gonna leave i think
you're threatening him
like well you know that um tom at work
thinks i'm pretty what do you think i i
think that's what you're doing
hey
i feel like i was pretty laid out but i
mean but you're not going yeah
well now i'm thinking um about just
taking my money that comes in from my
job and just putting it into a different
account no don't do that listen if you
do that number one
you are modeling for your daughters
what a strong powerful woman looks like
and you would be choosing to disconnect
your marriage even further under the
same roof
don't do that right don't
don't heal cancer by shooting yourself
in the foot
okay does that make sense
yeah so
i've got i mean i've had people from our
church talk to him um
i don't i don't know what to do at this
point
yes you do
oh you think it's like when you
when you have sat down with him
no listen when you've sat down with him
and said
i'm taking the internet out of this
house
you have to get a job
what does he say uh i know baby i know
i'm just uh i'm working what does he say
he he went out and got a part-time job
that's bullcrap why won't he go get jobs
oh yeah um because yeah there's ministry
or whatever i mean i got to the point
where i said i'm ready for this it's not
a ministry it's a waste of freaking time
it's not um it's
you cannot wrap up
a bomb
with like a little jesus ribbon on it
you can't do that
well i'm really working no it's over
close it tell him this that he is
choosing a part-time
failure
over you and your daughters
yeah
because that's what he's doing
because he's also
he's putting a picture not only of a
lazy partner
but he's
creating a
your daughters are growing up with a
exhausted resentful mom
because they pick up on your eye rolls
they pick up on your
they pick up on your
um
just you're gritting your teeth they're
absorbing all of that
yeah and it's becoming the air they
breathe it's becoming normal
yeah and you amy deserve more than that
am i telling you to divorce your husband
no but he's cheating on you with a
failing non-profit
he's cheating on you with the internet
and i'd be willing to i don't have a
great car it's a piece of crap to be
honest with you but i'd bet it
um
that he's got some sort of other
relationships on that computer too
whether it's pornography whether it is
his little political conspiracy theory
buddies
right whatever it is
he's got an alt universe that he lives
in
and my guess is he is probably depressed
beyond all depressed
yes
and he is in a s he is sitting in ash
and he doesn't know how to get up
and i can talk to him your friends can
talk to him people from church can talk
to him a counselor can talk to him but
until he decides
i want my life to be better for myself
for my wife for my daughters
until he can put the mouse down and quit
clicking
he's putting you in a position to have
to choose the life of your daughters
to choose your life
does that make sense
no it makes perfect sense so i am not
telling you to leave your i'm not
telling you to leave your husband okay
i hate divorce i'm high on marriage i
love it
but he's drowning your family
and i don't think this is just me i
don't think you've been clear with him
i think you have tried your best to be a
peacekeeper
yeah is that fair maybe tell me if i'm
wrong tell me i'm wrong no it no you're
right i i mean i'm always trying to help
him find the next solution
and give an idea of you know just a
band-aid trying to always apply a new
band-aid that's right
so there's something else going on in
his life
that he's either hiding from you or he's
drowning in
and it's time for all of that to come
into the light
and here's my guess amy and you
tell me if i'm right
my guess is there's other people that
you're going to with your challenges or
your frustrations or you're have
you're on a fast track to finding
another life too if you haven't already
i mean i just talk to a counselor
i try to you know i try to do it right
or i talk to
women from my church you know i try to i
try to do it right i mean
but it's hard
yeah
and somebody else you know i've spoken
openly with him whenever people are men
that have given paid attention to me and
i said you need to know that this is how
affairs get started because someone is
dissatisfied in marriage and then
someone else starts giving them
attention and so you need to do a better
job in this marriage
and he's and he's been very receptive to
that and said you know i'm sorry and
things get better temporarily and
and so we're just always on this it gets
a little bit better it goes back to
normal
you're drowning
okay that's like you find a hole in your
boat and he puts a piece of duct tape
over it and you're drowning
yeah so all you got to rip the router
out of your house
i thought about that
disconnect the internet today disconnect
it
and tell him in my house and our house
we're not gonna have internet we're
gonna have each other
and you tell them i made an appointment
at such and such family therapist you're
coming and if you choose not to come
you're sending a very clear signal that
you think this marriage is over
yeah
and there cannot be ambiguity there
cannot be any more peacekeeping there
cannot be any more protecting his
feelings
because you are drowning
like when you're a lifeguard and
somebody's drowning they will and they
will hit you they will grab you they'll
drown you too they will tell you to
elbow them or punch them to get them to
stop so that you can get both of you to
shore okay i'm not telling you to elbow
or punch your you punch him what i'm
telling you is you're trying to stay
wrapped up with somebody who's drowning
you
right
yeah okay so all the lights come on
tonight
all of them
or you let him know tomorrow i'm taking
a half day of work the kids are going to
such and such and we are having this
conversation and if you've got somebody
that you trust
a counselor you can have this
conversation in front of them great
it may be good for you to go to your
counselor and say i'm at my or what
moment
because i will not let my daughters grow
up in this i will not be held hostage by
a
waste of time failing
non-profit that prohibits my husband
from getting a job or from being a
present father or for putting down
stupid political crap and being present
in our family
i will not be second rate to a youtube
channel and a whatever whatever whatever
and by the way
nonprofits are awesome non-profit
ministries are awesome
but they don't take precedence over your
family they don't take precedence over
eating and they don't take precedence
over
um
math
they have to work people have to want to
be a part of these things that's what
that's a whole other thing
amy i'm sorry
i'm sorry
but the dancing and the peacemaking is
over now we're in it now you're in it
lights are on you're going to get
somebody to sit with you you're going to
walk through here's the things that are
going to be different in my home you're
going to ask your husband to be a part
of it and you're going to let him know
clearly and unequivocally not with
threats not with well you know bill
thinks i'm pretty none of that crap no
that well i've got another apartment if
you don't none of that
those games are over
you got two little girls watching this
whole thing play out
absorbing every second of it they
deserve better than this you deserve
better than this he deserves better than
this
he's got to get help for his whatever
addictions he's got which he does he's
got to get out of these other
communities which he is and he's got to
get help for his depression
and somebody who loves him is going to
flip all the lights on and say done
somebody says done
so i want you to let me know how that
goes
let me know how it goes okay and it's
gonna be hard and it may not go great
all right or this may be
finally
finally right
thank you so much for that call amy
hey you know what we got a great song
it's
the greatest song ever written given to
us by sarah in the booth
probably one of the worst transitions
from that call to this song but hey
we're in it now and i've already got the
lyrics here
great
oh man hey you know what maybe it's
maybe it's perfect maybe it's perfect
it's off the back to the future
soundtrack kids and if you don't know
that's that movie stop everything quit
your jobs tell your kids they'll be fine
go watch back to the future good grief
don't do any of the things i just said
but watch back to the future it's off
the back to the future soundtrack
by the one and only hl in the news the
huey lewis
i don't even know why i'm cheering like
that guy's so rad dude huey lewis is so
rad that guy doesn't need a hype man he
doesn't he's his own hype man they just
break into acapella songs in the middle
they just jam and they have a congo
player for no reason it's so good huey
lewis and the news off the back to the
future soundtrack the song is the power
of love and it goes like this
the power of love is a curious thing
make a man weep make another man sing
change a hawk to a little white dove
cool
more than a feeling that's the power of
love tougher than diamonds rich like
cream stronger and harder than a bad
girl's dream make a bad one good and the
wrong one right
huey what are we doing here
power of love that keeps you home at
night you don't need money don't take
fame don't need no credit card to ride
on this train you can probably use a
debit card though because i'm at dave
ramsey's place
it's strong and it's sudden it's cruel
sometimes but it might just save your
life that's
the power of love right here by dr john
dolone's show